foreign
looks like things between Kim Kardashian
and Tom Brady are purely platonic what's
going on after rumors began swirling
that the two are dating et's learning
they're just friends people don't see
the context behind it the stores tell us
E.T Tom and Kim have been in touch
because Kim's looking to buy property
where Tom has a vacation home yep with
Tom Brady's rep denying any romance
Kim's last public relationship with Pete
Davidson played out last year on Hulu's
the Kardashians Pete is has got to be
literally the best human being I've ever
met like the best heart he's just super
genuine the couple dated for nine months
and since their split ETS learned Kim's
putting herself out there again what are
all the possibilities that can happen
what's my life going to look like the
source ads her family's also encouraging
her to get back in the dating game why
not by the looks of the Kardashians
upcoming third season Kim's certainly
making light of any romance rumors guys
oh God I have some very important news
no by who the 500 people I'm dating
it's a lot while it's unclear how much
fans will get to see of her navigating
this new chapter being open is something
Kim's always believed in we've filmed
everything from deliveries to marriages
divorces and our motto is like we just
we all film and
we just sit on it you know by the time
editing happens and you know the show
comes out so many different stories have
been made up that other people have kind
of made up about our lives without
you know a lot of the truth being out
there just without our story being out
there so I think it's always we
committed to this at the beginning which
was almost 12 years ago and we you know
have always stayed true to who we are
and always shared pretty much everything
so that's just who we've been
[Music]
foreign